Hello, everyone.
And welcome to
lecture 8 of CME 296.
So today is a special
day because as you know,
today is the last lecture
of this entire class.
So the menu for today will
be a little bit different.
What we'll do is we'll divide
this lecture into two parts.
In the first part, we'll
try to piece together
everything we've seen in
the class up until now
and see what we can
take away from it.
And in the second part,
what we'll look at
is adjacent fields where we can
apply what we've have learned.
Does that sound good to you?
So with that, what
we'll do is we'll
start with the first part,
which is just piecing together
everything we've
seen this quarter.
And the whole goal
of this class has
been to learn how
to generate images.
So, for instance, given an
input prompt, how can we
generate an image
that is quite aligned
with the prompt as input.
And of course,
there is just a lot
of dimensions we can look at.
So this class has
been about decomposing
the fact of learning how it
works into tractable parts.
And if you remember,
the first three lectures
were about just understanding
how we could generate images.
Just let's suppose we
have a black box model.
What is the paradigm
that would allow
us to just generate images.
So the first lecture was
about diffusion, just
learning how we could do that
using the diffusion paradigm.
And if you remember the
first thing we said was,
what could be a good
starting point for us
to generate those images?
So if you think
about it, the images
that we want to
generate they are
a part of a data distribution
that we do not know.
And that data distribution
can be complex,
and it's difficult
to sample from it.
So one thing we said was,
what are some distributions
that we know how to sample from?
So one such distribution was
the Gaussian distribution.
And what we said was
maybe in order for us
to sample from this
complicated data distribution,
one thing we could
do could be to sample
from an easy
distribution and then
make our way up to the
complicated data distribution.
So in this first
lecture, what we
said was let's represent
images with just
a multi-dimension variables
that we could denote x.
And what we said
was in order for us
to learn how to go
from Gaussian noise
to clean images,
what we'll do is
we will come up with
a forward process
that we define that will allow
us to corrupt clean images
into noise.
And the purpose of
diffusion is to learn
how to reverse that process.
So if you remember,
the forward process
was a nice formulation
that involves also
Gaussian distributions.
And so in order for
us to derive the form
of that reverse
process, what we did was
we tried to maximize the
likelihood of seeing the data
distribution under p theta.
And we went through
several steps that
allowed us to derive a loss.
So if you remember what we said
was maximizing the likelihood
is actually not tractable.
So what we do is we derive
a tractable lower bound,
which was something where we
used the forward process that we
defined in it.
So this lower bound
is called ELBO.
And what we did is
we expanded the terms
within that lower bound.
And we showed that we
could actually compute it.
It was actually tractable.
And we ended up
with a loss on us
trying to estimate the noise
that was added to a given image
through this very
simple L2 regression
loss, which had a noised image
as input along with its noise
level.
And what it was trying
to do was to estimate
the amount of noise that
was added to the image
or to the noisy
image, I should say.
So this was a first way
of looking at things.
So diffusion allowed us to
go from an easy to sample
from distribution, so
the Gaussian distribution
to the data
distribution by learning
how to remove the noise.
The second lecture
was about another way
of doing things, which was let's
look at this data distribution,
not from noise that
you need to remove,
but more in terms of
where you need to go.
And we looked at
a quantity called
the score, which was defined as
the gradient of the log of p.
And we saw that that
quantity had nice properties.
And in particular, it
allowed us to not worry
about that normalizing
constant that is intractable.
And what the score
was telling us
was where to go in order to
land at that data distribution.
And in particular,
there was a nice formula
from Langevin dynamics,
which basically
said that if you knew
how to compute the score,
then what you could do
is sample from noise
and make your way to
the data distribution.
So the whole goal
of this lecture
was to derive a way to
estimate that score.
So the problem is the score is
not the quantity that we know.
So what we did was have a
way to introduce the Gaussian
distribution to some
extent so that we
can leverage the properties
that we know from the Gaussian
distribution.
And in particular,
the fact that we
knew how to compute
in an analytical way
the score of a
Gaussian distribution.
So what we did is we took
observation from the target data
distributions.
And what we did
is we noised them.
And then we looked at how
we could estimate the score
of the noise distribution.
So we saw that it was something
that we could actually compute.
But then there was a trade off.
The more noise you would put
in the data distribution,
the more your noise
data distribution
would be far from the data
distribution of interest.
But then when you
do that, you're
able to estimate the score of
the noise data distribution
quite easily.
So you have a trade off of
you can compute the quantity,
but it's not the quantity
that you actually
want versus if you have only
a small amount of noise,
then the score of that low
noise data distribution
is actually not something that
you can estimate very well.
But the target that
you want to estimate
is closer to the actual
quantity that you want.
So you had this trade
off, and what we said
was, well, how about we
estimate the score, not just
as a function of
where we are in space,
but also as a function
of data distribution is.
And we ended up with the
de-noising score matching
loss, which allowed
us to estimate
the score of that
noisy distribution,
given a noisy image
and a noise level.
And once we did
that, we actually
saw that this way
of looking at things
was actually very similar to the
way we did in the first lecture
with diffusion.
And we saw that actually the
score of the forward process
is equal to minus the noise that
you added over some coefficient.
So both approaches led
to similar formulations.
And we saw that we
actually had this identity.
And then what we did
was just realized
that the way we were noising
our data distribution
was in a discrete way, and that
there are many choices that you
had to take at the
very beginning,
such as how many steps you
want to take and so on.
And so this motivated us to
move from discrete formulation
to a continuous formulation.
So we derived the
continuous formulation
of the forward process,
which allowed us to come up
with this stochastic
differential equation, which
is the delta in position
during the forward process,
which is equal to a drift
term that is deterministic,
plus a diffusion term,
which is stochastic.
And here we're using the
continuous equivalent
of the noise, which as we saw
was the Wiener process, dW.
And you could
actually figure out
how to move your x when you
want it to noise it with respect
to these two terms.
And we actually saw
that the first approach
that we looked at in the
first lecture and then
the second approach
that we looked at here
were actually special cases
of this more generic formula.
In particular, the DDPM
formulation from lecture 1
was a variance-preserving
formulation,
whereas the one that we saw
with the noise condition
score networks was actually a
variance exploding formulation.
And then what we
did was OK, our goal
is not just to noise images.
Our goal is to learn
the reverse process.
And so in order to do that,
the nice thing was that
in the '80s, we have a nice
results that told us that
for a given forward process,
you could have a corresponding
reverse process where you
actually needed to know
the score, which is actually the
quantity that we're estimating
here.
So what we had to do was just
to estimate the score in order
to reverse the process.
So long story
short, lecture 1 we
saw in order to go
from noise to clean,
we need to predict
the noise to remove.
In lecture 2, we said,
in order to go from noise
to clean, we need to know
where we want to move towards,
which is the score.
You can think of the
score as a compass
that tells you where the
data distribution is located.
And then we ended up
in the third lecture
with a third way of
looking at things, which
is the flow matching
formulation, which actually
framed the problem
in a different way.
So what we did there was to
consider the noisy distribution
in the beginning as just
an initial distribution,
and the data
distribution of interest
was just a target distribution.
And the goal for us
was to figure out
how to move your
probability density
from an initial distribution
to a target distribution.
So that's the flow matching
way of looking at things.
It's the point of view
of mass transport.
And in particular,
there was one quantity
that was very
important, which is
called the vector
field or the velocity,
which is denoted Ut of x.
It is a vector that is
defined at every position
and at all time t.
And what we saw
was that in order
to move each observations
from one point
to another, what we had
to do was to just follow
the vector field.
So we had this microscopic way
of looking at things, which
is the ODE that you see here.
So the dx over dt, which
is equal to the vector
field at that time
t and at position x.
And we also had a second way
of looking at this same thing.
So the first formulation is
the microscopic formulation,
which is what is happening
to your individual particles.
The second way of looking
at this same thing
is at the macro
level, where what
you say is the evolution of the
probability at a given time t
is equal to minus the
probability flux, which
is what constitutes the
continuity equation, which just
tells you that you're not
losing anything between time t
equals 0 and 1.
And the whole point of us
going into these formulas
was for us to figure
out a vector field which
would allow us to go from
this initial distribution
to this target
data distribution.
So this was the whole point.
And in particular, let's assume
you know the vector field
that you want to estimate.
The strategy here would
be to have a model that
estimates the vector field.
So here, Ut theta of x.
So let's assume you
learn such a model.
If you do learn
such a model, then
in order to sample from
the complicated data
distribution which is
p1, what you need to do
is to just sample
from your easy data
distribution p0 and
then numerically
solve the [INAUDIBLE] here
between times 0 [INAUDIBLE]
using the vector field
that you have learned.
And we saw that it's
actually something
that you can do in practice if
you construct the target vector
field in a way that
makes it tractable.
So we saw conditional
probability paths,
which were an easier
way of looking
at this, which is we
don't know what the vector
field in the general case.
How about if we look
at a simpler case where
we want to move the initial data
distribution, not to the target
data distribution,
but to a single point,
which was the conditional
probability path that we saw?
And we saw that we could obtain
a conditional flow matching
loss that was equivalent to you
learning the vector field that
was the aggregate of all these
conditional vector fields that
allowed you to solve
the problem of interest.
So these first three
lectures were by far the most
mathematically challenging.
I hope what I said made sense.
We spent six hours on this.
And I hope I did a
good job in 10 minutes
to just recap what we did.
At the end of it, I just
want you to remember
that so we're in 2026.
People nowadays they use
flow matching by default.
And so if you just
want to have something
that you want to really
master perfectly,
I would recommend just really
understanding the flow matching
part because this is what
most models nowadays use.
In particular,
they use a variant
that we saw that's called the
rectified flow variant, which
was an extension of this
that allowed the path
to be straighter, so
that at inference time,
you could afford having fewer
steps in the numerical solver
here so that you can just
sample images with fewer steps.
Oof.
So first three lectures,
mathematically challenging.
It was purely for us to learn
a paradigm to generate images.
But up until that point,
we assumed two things.
So the first one is we assumed
that we were generating
images in an unconditioned way.
So we didn't have
any input prompts.
We did not worry about this.
And the second thing was
we just assumed that we
had a way to represent images.
So we just represented them
with x with, I don't know,
n dimensional vector.
But we did not see what
representation would make sense.
And this was the focus of
lecture 4, which was titled
latent space and guidance.
And what we saw there
was, well, in order
to have a meaningful
representation of your images,
what you want is to have a way
to keep only the useful stuff.
So how do you do that?
Well, in pixel space,
you see that you
have a pretty large amount
of spatial correlation, which
means that if you
look at a pixel,
a lot of the surrounding pixels
are more or less of that value.
So you can imagine that there is
a lot of redundant information
in there.
So that's number 1.
And number 2 is in
the pixel space, well,
the dimensionality
is pretty high.
So given that the model that
you're going to build from it
is going to be a function of the
dimension of your input, what
you want to do is to make sure
your input is not too big.
So you want to
compress the input
into something that is only
keeping you the useful bits.
And in order for
us to do that, we
looked at a model that was
called an autoencoder, whose
only goal was to learn a way to
represent images into a smaller
space.
That's called the latent space.
So here on the slide, you
see that you have the image
in the pixel space as inputs.
And then you have an encoder
that does some downsampling
operations that gets you some
representation of the input
image, not in the pixel space,
but in a lower dimensional
space, which is
the latent space.
And what you do here is to
use that lower dimensional
representation in order
to reconstruct your input.
So you have a proxy task,
which is how can you
reconstruct the input
as best as you can
by going through
this bottleneck.
And when you do
that, you are indeed
able to learn a latent space
that compresses the information
into just fewer dimensions.
But then the problem
that we encountered
was that if you did that,
you had no way of controlling
the shape of the latent space.
And in particular,
if you want to learn
how to generate
images, what you want
is to have an easy
time at learning it.
So you don't want a space
with spikes here and there
and then nothing in between.
So what you want
is something more
at the top of the slide, which
is a data distribution that
is more compact and
well put together.
So in order for us
to do that, what
we did was go back to the
way we formulated things
and add a constraint for us to
regularize the latent space.
And this was the
VAE that we saw--
the variational autoencoder--
which allowed us to structure
the latent space in a way that
would make our lives easier.
And we saw that in order
to derive a loss for us
to learn that model, we use the
same trick as lecture 1, which
leverages the ELBO.
So the evidence lower bound.
I'm not going to
go into details.
But one thing I
wanted to say here
is we ended up with a
loss that had two terms.
One was the pixel-wise
reconstruction loss,
which we had
previously, but also
a second term that was aiming
at structuring the latent
space as much as possible to
a certain distribution that
was called the prior
distribution, p of z,
so that we can have something
that looks a little bit more
like the top one.
Cool.
So that was really the
focus of that session.
And we also learned how
to represent the input.
So we saw different encoders,
in particular transformer-based
encoders, including the
VIT-- vision transformer.
And then we saw
that there are ways
to combine different
modalities in the same space,
for instance, with CLIP
using a contrastive loss.
And then we also saw methods
to incentivize our generation
to be more aligned
with our condition.
And here, if you
remember, we looked
at classifier-free guidance
that allowed us to do that.
Cool.
So up until that
point, we knew how
to generate images in
terms of the way we
wanted to go about doing this.
We knew how to
represent the inputs.
And we knew how to
represent our noisy latents.
Well, now the question is, what
model are you actually going
to use to do that?
And this was lecture 5,
which was on image generation
architectures.
And here we took a step back
and just reminded ourselves
of the problem that we have at
hand, which is we have a model.
And what we want
to do is to predict
a quantity that will allow
us to go from noise to clean.
So as I mentioned, the paradigm
that is by far the most common
these days is the flow
matching paradigm.
So it's, in particular, a model
that would predict the velocity.
So what we want is
a generation model
that takes in a noise level,
the condition of interest,
like your user prompt, and then
your noisy latent as inputs
in order to predict
the velocity.
And we saw that one
popular architecture
was the U-Net, which was
composed of two main parts.
The first one was a
downsampling part,
which allowed to gain a global
understanding of the inputs
through downsampling
operations, which
allowed its receptive field
to be bigger and bigger.
So here what we mean is when
you compute the activation map,
if you take a single
value, what we're saying
is that that value was a
result of a pretty wide input.
So that's the downsampling part.
And then the upsampling
part was just a way
for us to match the
shape that we wanted.
And we had this copy
and crop connections
that allowed us to transfer
lower level details that
were computed as part of
the downsampling operation.
So this was the U-Net.
But of course, you know that
in 2017, transformers just
took the whole field by storm.
And there was more
and more models
that were relying
on the transformer
and the self-attention
mechanism.
And it was not long after
that the diffusion transformer
came into play.
So in 2022, I believe.
So that architecture dealt with
a limitation of the U-Nets,
which was that patches
that were far from one
another from the
image could not have
a direct way of interacting
with one another.
And in cases, like if you
wanted to generate an image,
let's say, a teddy bear that
looks at himself in the mirror,
then you would want to have
that interaction to figure out
the lower level details.
And we saw that
diffusion transformer
was injecting conditions
using an adaptive layer norm
framework.
So it was just modulating the
embeddings of the patches.
And then we saw that--
today is May 29th 2026.
So now we have a lot of
such models out there.
And in particular, there
is one specific category
that has emerged, which is
the multi-modal diffusion
transformer, which
on top of doing
this self-attention
mechanism, also considers
the condition as part
of the joint attention.
And we looked at the timeline.
So here what's in blue is U-Net.
And what's in green
is DiT and variants.
And of course, the
timeline is not exhaustive
but it is just a way for you
to see that nowadays image
generation models are
almost everyone is relying
on the DiT-based architecture.
Cool.
And then at that stage, we knew
how we could generate images.
We knew how to
represent the input.
represent the latentce.
We knew what model
to use, but we
didn't how to train that model.
And that was the
focus of lecture 6.
And so before digging
into the details,
one thing we wanted
to just align
was how we wanted our
time step to be sampled
during the training, because we
had seen back in lecture 1 to 3
that the time step that
we were sampling in order
to train our model was drawn
from a uniform distribution.
And we spent some time just
thinking about whether all noise
levels are equally hard or not.
And we saw that noise levels
that are not super noisy,
but not towards clean,
like those in the middle,
were the most
difficult because those
were the places where we had
to make important decisions
about where to go.
And so that's the
reason why the fact
of sampling from a
uniform distribution
was not the most optimal.
And we saw that there
was this distribution
called the logit-normal
distribution, which
is a distribution that focuses
much more on the middle steps,
was something that was more
commonly used these days.
And we saw that not only
that, but the resolution
of your images also
matter in terms
of what the perceived noise is.
And in particular, if
you want to train a model
on higher resolution
images, what
you want is to
make sure to noise
your images a bit more than
what you did previously, because
for a given noise level,
a lower resolution image
will appear as being more noisy
compared to higher resolution
one.
And we did some math on the
blackboard, if you remember,
when we computed
just the uncertainty
around the underlying
pixel value.
But intuitively, it
comes from the fact
that there is spatial
correlation within your image.
So if you have more
pixels to represent,
let's say, an area of the image,
well, if you noise some of it,
and if you have more chances
to see the actual value,
then when you look
at the image, you
will have an easier
time to see what
the image is about as opposed to
if you have a lower resolution
image.
So if you have pixels
that are noised,
then you have fewer
chances of seeing
the underlying true pixel
value-- denoise pixel value.
And so with that,
we saw that there
are a few stages to a
typical model training
process, the first one
being pre-training,
which is learning how
to generate images.
And so here you have-- so
it's the most time consuming
and expensive part of
the whole pipeline,
because you need to come up with
a very big corpus of images that
encompasses all of
the possible images
that you want to generate.
And it needs to be
certain quality,
and you need to have
good mixtures and so on.
So a lot of effort is put into
having a pre-trained data that
is reflective of the
way you want your image
generation to learn.
And after that, we
saw that once you
get an image
generation model that
knows how to generate
images, what you wanted to do
is to generate good images.
And in particular, good
here can be something
that people say just
in the aesthetics term.
So you want your
image to look good,
but you also want
your image generation
model know how to generate
images in your field of interest
or in your task of interest.
So, for instance, if you have
an image generation model that
has been pre-trained
on, let's say, nature
and then, I don't know,
houses, but if you
want that model to
generate images, let's say,
teddy bears, so what you
want is, for instance,
to have an extension
of that training
that we call continued training,
where you teach your model how
to generate images in your set
of images of interest, which
here can be teddy bears.
And what we saw was that
a third optional step
could be the tuning step, where
you could have a situation where
you want to generate images
of one particular subject,
of one particular
person many times.
So if you are in that
situation, what you want
is to tweak your model in
a way that will remember
what you wanted to generate.
And we saw DreamBooth as
a way for us to do that.
So the idea was to gather
a set of images of 5 to 10
typically that contains
who you want to depict.
And what you do is
you train your model
to generate images that
contain that specific person
or that specific object, while
having a rare token as input.
So what you are
teaching your model
was to rewire its brain
towards generating something
when it saw a specific token.
And given that these
models can be pretty big,
we saw that there
were also techniques
to tune, not all
weights, but a subset
of the weights through this
technique called LoRA--
low-rank adaptation.
And once you did that--
let's suppose you did either
the first two or all three
of the steps.
What you want is to now deploy
your model to production.
So what you want is to have a
model that does not cost you
a lot and also does not take a
lot of time to make generations.
So we saw a bunch
of methods that
were aimed at shortening the
number of steps that were needed
for you to generate samples.
So this category of methods
is called distillation.
So we saw a number of methods.
So I would encourage you
to look at that lecture.
So there was progressive
distillation as one example,
but some others as well.
And then finally, last week,
what we said was great,
we can do all of this.
But we have not seen how
we could evaluate how
our images, how good they were.
And if you don't
know how to do that,
well, you don't where
to put your efforts.
So you need to know
how well you're doing,
which is why lecture 7 was
focused on evaluating images
and in particular, how
good those images were.
So we saw that the most common
way people evaluate images
on things like leaderboards
is by having images generated
by the models that are
in your leaderboards
and by having pairwise
comparisons between them.
And we saw that there was a
particular way of measuring
performance that took
into consideration
the history of each model.
And by history, I mean how
people rated that model.
And the reason
for that is we saw
that if you were to win
against a weak week model,
it is not the same
thing as if you were
to win against a strong model.
So you want to take
into consideration
how strong your opponent
is, otherwise, a metric
like the win rates would be
very dependent on who you are
making your comparisons with.
And we saw this
metric called the Elo
rating, Elo score that looked
at this in the following way.
So if you were to rate different
models, so you have a ratings,
let's call it R, that quantifies
how good each model is.
So in order for you to--
let's suppose you
have a new model.
You want to compute its rating.
So what you would do is
compare that new model to,
let's say, a model that
is part of the list.
And you would use the
rating of the models
to quantify how good
they are, and take that
into consideration
in order to find
the rating of the new model.
So how do you do that?
Well, the idea is quite simple.
So the ratings quantify
how good models are.
So from that quantity,
what you can do
is to compute what you
expect will happen.
So for instance, if you have a
strong model and a weak model,
well, what you expect is
the strong model to win.
So you compute a
quantity which is
the expected score, which is a
function of these two ratings.
And you compare that
with the actual score.
And the difference between
that, which is here,
delta, tells you how
surprised you are.
So if you won against
a strong model, then
you want your delta to be high.
And if you won against
a weak model, then
it's not a lot of signal for
you because almost everyone
wins against that weak model.
So delta would be lower.
So all of that to say that
you will come across the Elo
score quite a lot.
And I just want you to
remember that the Elo score is
a smart way of computing
pairwise comparisons
by taking into consideration
how strong your opponent is,
if you compare model
A and model B. Cool.
But not everyone has the
luxury of having human ratings
for everything they do.
So that's why we also have a
bunch of automated metrics.
So we looked at one that
was quite popular nowadays,
which is called the FID score--
Fréchet inception distance.
So what this score
does is it computes
the distance between
the distribution
of your generated images and
the distribution of real images.
And the idea is if these
distributions are far,
then it means that
your generated images,
they don't look
like real images.
And we saw that the
FID score-- so I didn't
put the formula here,
but it is something
that is derived from a
more general formulation.
And here, the actual
formula is derived
considering that these
two distributions are
considered as Gaussian.
So that's the
assumption that we're
doing when we're
computing this metric.
And we saw that the lower this
metric was, the better it was.
And of course, it's a proxy.
So it's not a perfect metric.
And then we looked at more
clever ways of obtaining scores,
in particular, by leveraging
these newer models.
So here, MLLM, which stands
for multi-modal large language
models that are able to
both take texts, but also
images as input.
So you could very well
say, you have this image.
You have this input prompt.
Well, tell me how it looks
like or how good that is.
Then you could obtain
some given scores.
And we saw that you also had
a way to leverage these models
in order for you to not have
to ask your humans to rate
your images, but to ask
your MLLM as a judge to rate
them for you.
You could have a
tighter loop that
would allow you to make
iterations faster and have
human ratings when you feel
like your model is good enough
for you to take that step.
And this was CME 296.
So you see that in
order for us to generate
an image from a prompt, there
is a lot that goes underneath.
And this is what the whole
lectures 1 to 7 were about.
Cool.
So now you finish this
class after this lecture
and you're like, OK,
now I know all of this.
And so what?
So I wanted to talk to you about
the state of the art models that
were out there.
So what we did was just go
to a popular arena that ranks
the best models out there.
So there's a leaderboard.
And as you can see,
there is the Elo score
that is used to
determine those ranks.
And I just wanted for us to look
at which models were the best
and whether they were also
using the methods that we
saw in this class or not.
So let's start with the
best models out there,
and we see that we
have the first two
ranks that are from OpenAI.
So GPT Image.
And then we have two
models from Google.
And then the fourth--
sorry, the fifth
model is from xAI.
So it's all closed-source
models from top AI labs.
The problem with
those models is we
don't how they work
because they're not
publishing any reports.
So there's not a
lot I can tell you.
But that leaderboard also
ranks open weight models
that have technical
reports that are published
that are public and available.
So it's a screenshot that
dates from five days ago.
And we see that the
highest ranked model is
from a company called HiDream.
So it's HiDream-01-Image
number one.
And then you have Qwen Image
that we saw in lecture 5,
when we talked about the
multi-modal diffusion
transformer.
And then the ranks three
to five are from this model
from Black Forest
Lab called FLUX 2.
And what I wanted us to do
was to go through these models
and see what they were made of.
So let's start with the last
ones, the FLUX 2 models.
So they're based on rectified
flow, which, as I mentioned,
is a derivative
of flow matching.
So something that we know.
Their architecture is based
on the diffusion transformer.
But in particular, what our
architecture is based on
is a combination
of single stream
and double-stream
diffusion transformer.
So this is also
something that we saw.
So they rely on a
VAE to make sure
that the latent space is compact
and allows you to learn easily.
So that's also
something that we saw.
And we also happen
to have some text
encoder that was pre-trained.
And here.
It's a Mistral 3, that is used
to generate the embeddings.
So up until now, the usual.
Let's go to the model number 2.
So Qwen Image.
The loss is a flow
matching loss.
So also something that we know.
So the architecture is
a multi-modal diffusion
transformer.
And it also relies on a VAE.
And the text embeddings
are based on Qwen.
Also the usual.
Now let's look at the top-ranked
model, which by the way,
was published, I
think, two weeks ago.
So it's extremely recent.
So flow matching loss also
similar to what we saw.
The model is not exactly
a multi-modal diffusion
transformer, but
it's something that
is based on the transformer.
So also very similar.
But turns out that
there is no more VAE.
And there is no
pre-trained text encoder.
So does that mean that what
we learned was not true?
What's going on?
So let's see how that
relates to what we learned.
So that paper, what it does
is it actually performs
the generation, not in a latent
space, but in pixel space.
And now you may think, well,
how is the dimensionality going?
Because it's much higher
than a latent space.
So that's the first question.
And then the second
question is pixel space
is much harder for you
to learn because we
saw that in the space, valid
images in the pixel space
are more isolated.
They're not smooth distribution.
Well, here is my interpretation.
So first of all, for
the dimensionality.
So it turns out that the patch
size that the paper uses is not
the traditional 2 by 2 that
we're used to for latent space.
It's actually a much bigger one.
So it's a 32 by 32.
So computationally
here, the idea
is to make it tractable by
just having bigger patches.
And then when it
comes to learnability,
well, the fact of not having
an easy space to learn from
is just shifting the
effort that needs
to happen over to the
diffusion-based transformer.
And so what I found very
interesting with this paper was
even if you make your problem
harder for your diffusion
transformer or your
transformer-based model, well,
you can still have
amazing results,
if you scale it well enough.
Because that model,
well, turns out
that it was scaled, I
believe, to 8 billion
and then also to 200
billion parameters, which
is huge for image
generation models.
And so what I wanted to say was
that the space is fast moving,
that what we talked
about still holds true,
but that the trade off
between making it easier
for the transformer to learn
versus doing it in the raw space
is still something that was
being figured out because there
is something that I
have not mentioned,
which is when you
learn the latent space,
so you're making it easier
for your model to learn.
You're having a
more compact space.
But then the main thing
that you're losing
is fidelity, because it's
a lossy operation for you
to operate in a space that
is not your original space.
So when you know train
your VAE, you just
hope that you will
reconstruct things truthfully.
But it is not always the case.
And it just turns
out that this paper
shows that the
downside of the VAE
are such that we could
maybe work without it,
if you scale things
in a big enough way.
So I found that interesting.
And I think it's a newer trend
of doing things without VAEs.
So I think it's just good for
us to keep an eye on this.
So again, this paper was
published a few weeks ago.
I don't want to make general
statements because maybe
in a couple of months,
then we will see maybe
that the VAE is necessary.
But I think this is a part
that is worth watching.
Cool.
So any questions on that?
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
So the question is,
what is the alternative
to pre-trained encoder?
So the alternative is to
just learn it yourself.
So instead of having
a pre-trained encoder
computing the embeddings
for you, what you do
is you take the text as input.
What you do is you
just tokenize it.
So you divide it into
arbitrary units of text.
And you learn the representation
as part of your training.
And so there's one
thing I didn't say here,
but they're not using a
pre-trained text encoder
to do that, but they're doing
some kind of prompt enhancement
that allows you to be more
explicit about the input prompt,
because you may have a prompt
like a teddy bear is reading.
But in order to generate
a very good image,
you need to know, for instance,
how the lighting should be,
what camera position
should be, and so on.
And so that piece is also making
the job of the text encoder
easier because it
just explicits what
you need to have as condition.
Yeah.
So the question is, if there
is no disjoint text encoder,
how are they able
to understand text?
So here the key
word is pre-trained.
So there's still a text encoder,
but it's just not something
that you take off the shelf.
It is something that
you train yourself
as part of the training.
OK, cool.
So this concludes part 1,
which was around recapping
what we did up until now.
So now that we know all of
this, what I want us to do
is to see how adjacent
fields can benefit
from what we have learned.
And a very natural extension
that I want to talk to you about
is videos.
So if you think
about it, videos are
nothing else than a sequence
of frames which are images.
So you just have
an extra dimension.
So here you go from a 2D image
to a 3D image across time.
And the question now for
us is, what should we
have in mind when we want to
build a video generation model?
And what are the
things we can use
from what we have
learned in order for us
to be able to do that?
So the first thing
that I want to tell you
is there is an extra
dimension, which is time.
The second thing that I want
to talk to you about is that
in a video, you need to make
sure that there is some temporal
consistency, as in you cannot
go from one frame to the other
in a way that completely
changes what you're looking at.
But you also need to
make sure that whoever
is being depicted in your frames
do not have suddenly things
that they did not have.
So, for instance,
if you're looking
at a video of a
teddy bear reading,
you don't want that teddy bear
to all of a sudden acquire a hat
and sunglasses at t plus 1, but
then at t not have any of those.
So this is an extra thing
that you need to worry about.
So for images, you
want it to generate
something that was plausible.
For videos, you need
to generate something
that looks plausible
at a given time t,
but you also need to make
sure that the way frames are
sequenced is also making sense.
So you need to have that
temporal consistency.
And of course, you need to
make computations tractable
because here, as
you can imagine,
if we go the route of
representing our input
as a sequence of
2D images, well,
the dimension just got
increased by a factor of t,
which is the time.
And so you need to make sure
that whatever you're doing
is making things
still tractable.
And of course, metrics as well.
And well, I'll just
get you the spoiler.
So we still leverage the metrics
that we have seen for images,
but we just extend
them for videos.
So the Fréchet
inception distance--
FID-- is something that you may
also see in the video worlds
where the only
thing that changes
is the representation
of the quantities
that you're dealing with.
So instead of having the
Inception network to represent
your image, what
you're doing is you're
using a pre-trained encoder that
would represent your videos.
And you have, for instance, this
metric called the Fréchet video
distance, that tells you how far
apart your generated videos are
from real ones using
a similar method.
But I want to call
out one thing.
These metrics are just proxies.
So it's always good to
have human in the loop.
So now let's see how we can
handle just generating videos
by going through specific
parts of the architecture
that we may need to change.
So if you think about it,
an image generation model,
a traditional image
generation model
is a DIT-based model
operating in a latent space.
So you have a VAE that
compresses your input
into some latent space.
And then you obtain, let's
say, the final prediction
that you then decode back
in your initial space.
Well, the same thing is
happening for videos.
So here, you not
only are compressing
from a spatial
perspective, you're
also performing a
temporal compression.
So do you remember
when we talked
about f, which was the
ratio of the heights
in your initial space over the
height in your latent space?
Do you remember?
So maybe I'll just quickly--
so we had this pixel space.
And then we have the
latent space here.
And then you have
H and then h here.
So we had f, the
spatial compression,
which was just the ratio
of big H over little h.
And that ratio is
typically on the order
of 8 for spatial compression.
Here what you also want to
do is to compress your input
along the time
dimension as well.
So, why do you want to do that?
Well, the first
thing is you want
to make sure your problem is
tractable from a dimensionality
perspective.
But then the second
reason is when
you compress things in a smaller
space, what you're assuming
is you have redundant
information.
So spatially, we saw that
we have spatial correlation,
meaning around some
pixels, you have
pixels of the similar value.
So you have redundant
information.
Well, it's the same along
the time axis as well.
Because you can
very well imagine
that if you go through
the frames of a video,
two consecutive frames will have
a lot of the same information.
So it would also make sense
for you to compress things
also along the time axis.
And so here, this
compression ratio,
which we saw was for
space, is also something
that we have along
the time dimension.
And as a result,
your latent space
is composed, not
of space latent,
but of space time latent.
So what that means is
the quantities represent,
not only things that are
within a given image,
but also with respect to time.
So there is one thing that
you may find interesting,
which is that the dimension
over t is 1 plus t
And then the latent space is
of dimension 1 over t over 4.
But then you may
ask, why the 1 plus?
Why 1?
And I would say it's
a good question.
It's also a question
I ask myself.
Well, it turns out that if
you want to generate a video,
you need to have
a starting point.
You need to have
an initial frame.
Well, that 1 is a way for us
to consider the first frame
as being something special.
It has a special place.
It's the anchor frame.
We want to make sure
we're representing
it as well as possible.
And so the reason why
we have the 1 plus
is to represent that first
frame, that anchor frame
to its fullest extent, and then
to use that as a way to continue
the video in a way that
is a natural continuation
of that first frame.
Does that make sense?
So by the way, we're going super
quickly over a lot of things.
So my goal is to just
give you some pointers
for if you're just interested,
let's say, after today,
and you want to
just explore more,
these are just some
small little things.
The second thing I wanted
to talk about with respect
to the VAE is so as we
said, it is not a 2D VAE.
It's a 3D VAE, because it's
operating also along the time
dimension.
So you will see that VAE
is called a causal VAE.
So why causal?
So causal is because when
you perform, let's say,
convolutions, which is typically
what one of the operations
that VAE contains, you
perform your convolution
in a symmetric manner.
But here, what you want
to do for a given frame
is to not compute
feature maps that are
a function of future frames.
You only want for
that frame to be
a function of the same
frame and the frames before.
So that is why it's
called a causal VAE.
It's because the convolution
is not like the symmetric one
that you're thinking of.
It's asymmetric.
And the reason why
people would do that
is actually for several reasons.
But one of the
reasons is you don't
want to go out of memory every
time you do these things.
So what people do
is sometimes they
stream this encoding process.
And if you make sure
that a given frame is not
dependent on the future frames,
which by the way, the receptive
field can widen if you have
several convolution operations.
So if you make sure
that it only depends
on that frame and the
frames before, then,
computationally speaking,
you can actually
stream that encoding
and decoding process.
I'm just giving you reason why.
And then the second
thing that I wanted
to talk about with respect
to the video-- oh, yeah.
You have a question?
Great question.
So the question is, why
would you need frames
before the last frame?
So let me give you an example.
So let's suppose a teddy
bear walks across the street.
And the camera looks
at that Teddy bear,
and it sees a pedestrian
that is coming this way.
And then later on, that
pedestrian comes back.
So the information of who is
going behind the teddy bear
is something that
is important to you.
You want to be able
to capture things that
makes your video consistent.
So that temporal consistency,
which is making sure you're
not inventing objects or
people in your video that
may have happened in the past.
So that's the reason why you
want your receptive fields
to not be one.
So you want to have some
dependency on earlier frames
compared to the last one.
Does that answer your question?
The question is yeah
efficiency concerns.
And yeah, I hear you.
So there is something
we'll discuss
which is exactly what is
happening in the latent space.
So, of course, you cannot
generate a video of very,
very big time t.
So what people do is
divide the generation
into several parts,
where you can
generate a video of,
let's say, a fixed length,
and then take the last
frame as the anchor frame
to generate another video of,
let's say, another fixed length.
So one way for you to
make this more tractable
is to just take the
last frame of the video
that you generated
as the first frame,
and then continue later on
along with some condition.
So yeah.
Yeah.
So the question
here is, how can you
teach your model how to
generate the next frame, given
some conditions?
So we're actually going to
see that in the next slide.
So this part is just about
compressing the inputs,
but we're not yet
generating the video.
So we're going to see
that in just one second.
But yeah, great question.
Cool.
Any other questions?
So I'll answer your
question right now.
The way we generate videos
is within that latent space,
similar to how we do it
for image generation,
we have this
DiT-based architecture
that works from patches
and that generates patches.
The main difference from
images is that these patches,
they are not space patches.
They're not spatial patches.
They're space time patches.
And what that means
is as input, we have,
if you want something that
represents some part of the,
let's say, image,
it's not really image
because you're in the
latent space across time.
And in order for you
to think that you're
doing a good job at
producing a video that
is consistent with
oneself, one thing
that you can tell
yourself when you're
looking at that whole process
is that within the DiT,
you have the self-attention
mechanism that allows your space
time patches to interact
with one another
so that you're
producing an output that
is coherent across space,
but also across time.
So I think your question
also involved some amount of,
how can you make sure that
it reflects causality?
So can you expand on what
you mean by causality?
So the question is,
how can you make
sure you have some causality
versus correlation?
I think at the end of
the day, what you're
doing is you're training
your model on some data,
and the resulting model is just
reflecting the patterns that it
has seen at training time.
So if you feed it things that
reflect, for instance, if you
put a book on a table,
and there's some dust that
goes away, these
are the patterns
that your model will also learn.
So I think at the
end of the day,
it all goes back to what
kind of data you put inside.
So that's how I
would think about it.
Yeah.
So the question is,
well, we know in LLMs,
we have a masked self-attention
that makes things causal.
Maybe there is something
that we can reuse here.
Well, in the image
generation world,
we're making sure that
all parts of the image,
they interact with one another.
And this is actually something
that we also have here,
the main reason
being that you want
some consistency between
every part of your video.
And so for that reason,
people typically
keep the full self-attention.
But then at the
end of the day, you
need to try it out
and see how it works.
[LAUGHS] But typically people
keep the self-attention.
Yeah.
OK, great.
So that model that we just saw
is a model that is open weights.
It's called Wan.
There are actually a
multiple models out there.
And this list of readings is
by no means comprehensive.
So in case you're
interested, feel
free to just take
a look at those.
So I know Wan is one such model.
I believe there's
also LTX as well.
Highly recommend
reading the papers.
I would say that given
the fact that you
know how image generation models
work, it's now much, much easier
to understand these papers.
So hopefully that's
going to be helpful.
Cool.
So video generation was
once adjacent fields
that I wanted us to touch on.
The second topic that I
wanted us to talk about
is image editing.
So let's imagine that
you have an image,
and what you want to do
is to edit that image.
So you can say, make this
image black and white.
So you could very
well use what we
have learned, which is you
put that into your text image
to image model.
So ti to i.
So, how do you do that?
Well, you represent
your condition,
which is the text and the
image as part of, let's say,
your MMDiT, and you inject that.
And you can obtain
an output image.
Well, the problem
here is that you're
considering this problem a from
scratch generation problem.
So you're telling your model,
make this image black and white.
And what you're expecting
is that exact same image,
but black and white.
And you can just ask yourself,
is it actually optimized
to what I'm doing?
So what I'm doing is
I'm asking a model
to generate a whole
thing from scratch.
And I have no guarantee
that it's the same image.
So the question here, is
there a better way for image
editing tasks to
edit your image?
Specifically, in cases where
you want the input image to be
preserved, is there a better
way to edit those images
than to consider this from
scratch generation problem?
Well, so in this case, you see
that the black and white image
had the teddy bear
raise its right arm.
And this is not what you want.
So people have been
thinking about this problem
from another angle.
So what they're saying is
instead of considering this
as an image generation
problem, let's actually
think about this problem as
an image editing problem.
And by editing, I mean,
in the sense of performing
some operations on the image.
So one idea could be
to have your image,
to have your prompt
be fed into a VLM.
So vision language
model, which is an MLLM--
multimodal large language model.
In order for you to receive
live editing actions that
could be maybe decrease the
brightness by, I don't know,
50%, just increase the
luminosity by x percent
that you could then interact
with an editing software,
like Photoshop, in order
to get your final image.
So the nice thing with this
approach is, well, first of all,
you have some guarantee
that you are preserving
your initial image,
if, let's say,
you're constraining the sets of
actions that you're taking to,
let's say, an allow
list of actions
that here can only be harmless,
like coloring actions.
But one challenge
is for your VLM
to know the set of
possible actions
well enough for the editing
action to actually make sense.
So that's the main challenge.
And so that's why some people--
I mean, when I say some
people, a lot of people
are trying to think
about how to do this.
So there's a very short list of
papers that try to resolve that.
But there is one method
that I want to mention here,
which is how do we want our
outputs-- like, how can we
make sure that our
output is something
that is aligned with
something that makes sense?
Well, a possible method is
to look at the logs of people
who are actually making edits.
So let's assume you go to your
favorite editing software.
You have an input image.
And then you make some edits,
and then you have a final image.
Well, the sequence of
edits that you made
is something that your
model can learn from.
Well, the only thing that
your model doesn't really know
is what your intent was,
because you typically
don't tell your
editing software, well,
I want to make my
image more like this.
You don't say that.
So these papers, so most of
them, what they're trying to do
is to come up with pairs of
initial image edited image,
along with the user intent that
is inferred by these two images,
let's say, from annotators.
And what they're
doing is they're
tuning the VLM on
these golden sets
in order to have it
behave more like something
that would tell you actions that
would correspond to your intent.
So that's why you
have papers on this.
It's just because that
in order for your model
to learn how to do
these things, you
need to do some work in
terms of which data to use,
how you want to
train these things.
And that's why they're here.
So I highly recommend
reading them.
It's an open area of research.
If you take a look at the
years they were published,
I mean, they were
published 2024, 2025, 2026.
So extremely hot.
Any questions?
Yeah.
So the question is, how can the
loss reflect the user intent?
Well, the thing is you
are not using the loss
to infer the user intent.
So one possible way of
inferring user intent
is to feed an off-the-shelf VLM
an initial image and an output
image and to tell your
VLM, well, tell me
what changed between
these two images
in order to infer this box,
make this image black and white.
So I'll give you an example.
If we feed a VLM the colored
image and the black and white
image, and we ask the
VLM, well, come up
with something
that tells me what
changed between
this and that image,
it gives you the user intent.
And then what you can do is
use that user intent along
with the initial image.
And then you can, of course,
collect the editing action
that the user took and
tune your VLM to output
these editing actions
given this input.
So that's one popular way
I've been seeing these papers.
[INAUDIBLE]
Yeah.
Cool.
Great.
So now we're in the
last part of what
I wanted to talk to you about.
And that part is
actually an area
that I think is a very, very hot
area, which is how can we apply
diffusion to the field of LLMs?
So as you know, there has been
a lot of transfer of knowledge
from what has worked well in the
text world to the vision world.
So in the text world,
as you know, in 2017,
we had the transformer
that was initially
designed for translation tasks.
So let's suppose you
want to translate
from English to French.
What you do is you use this
transformer to have some,
let's say, English
text as inputs in order
to have a generated
French text as output.
And as you know, well,
people in the vision world,
they adapted the
architecture in a way that
leverages some of the
scalability benefits
that the transformer
brings to the vision world.
And in particular, there
is one architecture
we have spent a
bunch of time on,
which is the diffusion
transformer, which
relies on that.
So that's one thing.
The next thing is
something we've briefly
talked about during,
I believe, lecture
6, which is around
post-training approaches,
and in particular, the fact
of injecting negative signals
into your model.
So there is this
tuning method called
DPO, which stands
for direct preference
optimization from the LLM world,
that was something that was
adapted to the diffusion world.
So that's one.
And another one that
you may be aware of
is GRPO, which now is widely
in use in LLMs that is also
something that
has been something
that people have experimented
with in the vision
world with flow GRPO.
So now you can ask yourself, OK,
text has given so much to us.
What can we give back to text?
Well, I know this class is
not about text, so I will not
go into the details.
But one thing I want to talk
about is that in the text world,
we are doing things mostly in an
autoregressive way, a little bit
like when you and I,
when we talk, what we do
is we generate one
word at a time.
And whatever comes
out is a function
of whatever came before.
Just to illustrate this, so you
have your LLM, which here we say
is autoregressive.
Let's call it an ARM LLM,
autoregressive model.
So here we have, let's
say, a token that says,
OK, we're starting the sentence.
So we say, A. And then
A goes into the model
along with everything that
came before and a teddy.
And we repeat it
again and again.
Teddy bear is reading.
We're generating sentences
by sequentially inputting
tokens one at a time and having
the model look at anything
that it has generated
before in order
to generate the next token.
Well, the problem with that is
that if your output sentence
or your output
response is long, then
you will take a lot of time
outputting that response
because the number
of iterations here
is in awe of the number
of tokens that you output.
So in particular, I'm not
sure if you do a lot of coding
on a day-to-day basis, but let's
suppose you want to, let's say,
code a huge thing, like
1,000 lines of code.
Well, what that model
is doing is really
outputting things one at a time.
It takes a long time.
And of course, you
want this to be quick.
Well, one idea is to borrow
this idea of diffusion for text.
So here what you can
think of is instead
of doing things one at a time,
how about we do everything
at once.
And we start from noise.
And what we do is we
progressively denoise in order
to obtain our final output.
Why wouldn't we do that?
So, by the way, it
sounds very non-natural
because I think you're
very used to saying things
in a sequential way.
But one analogy I
want to point out here
is let's suppose you're
writing a speech.
So first of all, I'm not sure
if you've ever written a speech.
But if you were
to write a speech,
you typically don't write
things in a very sequential way.
You first start with a draft.
You have some skeleton
of the bullet points
you want to talk about.
And then what you
do is you refine--
go from coarse to fine grained.
So what I'm saying is this
idea of doing everything
at once, something that
starts from noise up to clean,
although it's not natural, it
is not completely unreasonable
either.
Do you agree with
what I'm saying?
Yeah?
So let's suppose if we do
that, then what we would do
is reduce the complexity from
having the number of iterations
being in awe of number of
output tokens to being in awe
of the steps of diffusion.
So let's see how
we want to do that.
So let's assume we take
text with random noise.
And by the way, I'm not
defining noise just yet,
but just assume that the
text is noise in a way
that we'll see later.
Let's suppose we have
a diffusion-based LLM.
So what we're
saying is that we're
having this text with less
and less noise up until having
the cleaned text exactly
in the same way we
have done for images.
So I just want to make sure
this analogy is very clear.
Here, we're denoising the whole
input text in the same way
that we're denoising the
whole image all at once.
Well, a natural
question is we have
seen that we can think of
noise in the image world
as Gaussian noise.
But for text, it's a
little bit trickier.
And here's the reason.
In the text world,
things are discrete.
So you have words.
You have tokens.
You have this.
You have that.
You're not in a
continuous world.
So in the image world, you
would represent your noise
with a continuous multivariate
variable, typically
Gaussian noise.
But how would you do with text?
So one idea you can
have is let's just
throw whatever token we have.
That could be one option.
Well, the problem is each
token has a semantic meaning.
And so if you just take any
token and you put it as a way
to noise your
input, then you may
make your input
have a meaning that
is not a meaning you may
want your input to have.
So for that reason, one
thing that the field
is starting to align on, which
I believe is most common thing
is to have an actual
dedicated token, typically
a masked token that would just
represent a text token that you
would not know of.
So a noised text token.
So let's assume you do that.
Then how would we apply
what we have seen so far?
Well, we have seen
that for training--
so I will spare you all the
mathematical derivations which
some of these
papers they go into.
We will not go into
that right now.
But let's assume that we want
to mimic the training that we
have done for images.
How would we do that?
Well, we would take
a clean sentence,
as in an unmasked sentence.
And what we would do
is to corrupt the text
according to a noise level.
And so here, what
does that mean?
That means that we would have,
let's say, a t percent chance.
Let's suppose t equals 0.5--
a 50% chance of a token
in that sentence being masked.
So what we're saying is
let's suppose t equal to 0.5.
We're masking 50% of the tokens.
And then our
training strategy can
be to reconstruct
the tokens that
were masked as a function of
whatever was in the input that
was not masked.
That can be your
training objective.
So I know this is
not a text class,
but for those of you who
know about Bert, who's
an encoder-only
architecture, it also
has something that is similar
as a pre-training task.
The only difference is
here, the masking scheme
is done with respect to a
noise level that can change,
that can vary.
So you can have t,
like a lot of noise.
So almost everything
masked versus a little bit
masked, whereas for Bert,
it's always a certain amount
of masked token.
I just want to call that out.
So let's suppose you have that.
Then what you're doing is
you're teaching your model
to fill the blanks.
Well, now how would you go about
actually using such a model
at inference time?
So what you would do is same
as what we did for images.
Start with completely
noised inputs.
So here a sequence
full of masked token.
And then what you
would do is just
predict what would be hiding
behind those masked tokens
all at once.
But then you want to make sure
that you have enough buffer
for you to make corrections.
So you may want to revise some
tokens that you have predicted.
So the field has several
methods to do that, one of which
is just remasking some
tokens in a random way.
So some other methods, they're
mask tokens with respect
to some confidence scores.
For instance, if
you have a token
that you're unmasking that
you're not very sure of, then
you may want to
just do another try.
So here, you would take some
tokens that, let's say, you're
not sure of and remask them.
And what you would do is
to take that new sequence
and perform the same
operation, meaning
trying to see who is
behind that masked token.
And you do that again
and again until obtaining
your final outputs.
So this is a very high-level
way of how such a paradigm would
work for text.
Well, the good thing is there
is very active research on it.
And so I was reading
one of the papers.
So you can have speeds up to
10x compared to the traditional
autoregressive way
of doing things.
And that is particularly
useful for tasks
that requires you to have
response as quick as possible.
I know a lot of us are using
some form of coding agents to do
our coding work these days.
And I'm sure you
also want your agent
to finish as
quickly as possible.
Well, this paradigm would
allow you to speed up
that process significantly.
And that is the reason why
coding is a very good use
case for that paradigm.
So on the one hand
for the speed,
but on the second hand
also because in coding,
you naturally have a way
to be interested in filling
in the middle kind of tasks.
Because if you look
at your code base,
you're rarely always
trying to generate
things in a sequential way,
in an autoregressive way.
Sometimes you have
a bunch of code
and you just want
to generate code,
let's say, in the
middle of two functions.
So for filling the middle
tasks, that paradigm
is actually better compared
to autoregressive tasks.
And we will not have
time to go into details,
but training is
much more expensive,
particularly because
in the traditional way,
the way training works is
you input your whole input
and then what you're doing
is you're training your model
to predict the next token.
And you can parallelize
that very well.
And this is unfortunately
not something
that you can do as well
with the diffusion scheme.
And then the second
thing is there are so
many techniques that
now are specific to how
autoregressive models work
that you would need to adapt.
And there are also ways to
combine the benefits of the two
approaches.
And for instance, block
diffusion is an example of it.
So I just wanted to leave you
with these screenshots that just
tells you of the many
headlines that you
see around companies
that are betting
on this kind of technology.
So you have one such
company called Inception
that's actually founded
by a professor at Stanford
that's doing great.
And I will just leave you with
some suggested readings in case
you want.
And yeah.
That's a great question.
So the question is, how do
you handle the variable output
length?
It's a great question.
There are a few ways
you can deal with that.
But in practice, you
indeed need to set
a given length for your output.
And what you do is
you stop whatever
is after a special token
called end of sentence token.
Now, you can imagine
cases where you're
expecting a way bigger
output, but you always
have shorter outputs.
So you're wasting a
lot of computations.
So that's why the last
method I mentioned
is something that can be useful.
So block diffusion
is one approach
that's being worked on
where you're actually
generating text block by block.
So you're saying, OK, I'm
going to generate, let's say,
text of size, let's say, 100.
And I'm going to use
diffusion for that.
And once you generate
such an output,
if you didn't finish
the output, then you
will use that as a
condition to perform
another round of diffusion
for the second block
and so on and so
forth until hitting
an end of sentence token.
So you touch a very
good point, which
is there are some differences
between text and image.
And the variable
length is one of them.
Yep.
Yeah.
[INAUDIBLE]
So the question is,
can you apply this
to other discrete
things other than text?
I'm sure yes.
We will not cover this
today, but the ways people
have derived a tractable
mathematical way
to do that in the text
world is something
that involves transcribing
things for discrete items.
So I'm sure that it can be done.
So I would actually highly
recommend the first paper
for you to get a
sense of how people
go from continuous to discrete.
Yeah.
Yeah, great question.
So the question is,
can you not consider
text as just being a
screenshot of-- sorry,
can you not consider text
as being images of text
and use some kind of OCR
mechanism to process that?
So I think it's definitely
a great approach.
There's actually
a paper that was
published a few months
ago, DeepSeek OCR, that
goes into that.
I do think it's promising.
I believe there is some savings
with respect to how many tokens
that fills compared to how many
tokens the actual text would
fill in.
So it's definitely
another directions
that I think is promising.
Cool.
With that, I'll
give it to Shervine.
Thank you, Afshine.
So welcome to the last
stretch of CME 96.
So we're going to see
together some closing
thoughts on what
lies ahead, as well
as some challenges that we see.
So first, let's look at today.
So when you look at
existing top models,
what is the typical price you
have to pay for a perfect image?
So I did the research for you.
I looked at major
labs across the board,
and it seems that the price per
megapixel is of about $0.01.
And I think that's going to
be a useful metric to track
over time to see the
transition from this being
a nice thing to a commodity.
And of course, in reality, you
wouldn't use these top models
that I listed here, but
more of a distilled version.
But still, the upper
bound gives a good view
of what people would be ready
to pay for perfect quality.
But then let's look at the
kinds of challenges that could
be tackled in the near term.
So one thing that you
notice is that images,
they are doing
well on themselves.
But there are wins.
In other modalities that you
are inclined to include in order
to make generation
more powerful.
So one example that I have in
mind is reasoning with images.
So right now, anecdotally,
if you ask for a diagram,
you might get, with most
models, a projection
of what you asked on an
image, which is a nice start.
But it's not quite to the
same level of refinement
as the one you might get
in the text world, where
you ask a very precise
question and the model
goes in searching for
a meaning behind it
and then projecting the exact
answer in a concise way.
So that seems like a
good area of research.
And then one topic that
I've seen mentioned here.
So for image editing
use cases, it
seems that we're being
too hard on ourselves.
We're doing the whole generation
process that is, by nature,
unconstrained.
And it seems we
have an opportunity
to use existing tools and
wins in the text world,
to use agents and
existing human expertise
to make editing happen in a
constrained and tractable way.
And then you have
other use cases
that could seem
attractive to you all.
For example, learning
about a class,
you have several
streams of information
that come from texts, for
example, the slides, the lecture
video, and also the audio track.
So while you can put pieces
together one by one today,
it seems that there
is an opportunity
to bring all modalities to a
consistent and coherent way
and generate
synthesis out of this.
And in the longer run, you
can see the consequences
of all these benefits
across industries
that might be lagging because
of some inertia factor.
So you can think of so
the field of robotics,
which seems to be the
next area that could
benefit from a revolution.
So in text, we can generate text
now like roughly solved images.
Now we see great
images roughly solved.
And it seems we
have an opportunity
to feed all these learnings
into the ingredients that
could make robotics pick up, for
example, environments, but also
medicine and other
desk jobs that
might need their own
process of approvals
to actually
incorporate these wins.
And maybe one day you won't
need to come to lecture at all,
and there will be some model
gathering all the pieces for you
in a coherent and pedagogic way.
But I think we
might still be far
from that, because the fact of
transmitting knowledge still
requires that taste and opinion
that even the text world doesn't
have.
So I'm quite curious to
see when that will happen.
On the challenges side, so as
we have seen, there are costs.
And you can use distillation
to alleviate a bit of that.
But also, there is research
on the hardware side
where right now
hardware is built
on top of matrix multiplies.
But as you have seen,
the building block
of these days models is
transformers and which relies
on the concept of attention.
And this attention has a
very precise succession
of operations that you
could think of simplifying
in an analog to numeric way.
So this research paper
could be one such pointer.
But also one other concern
is the data quality side
because today, you
see all these images
that are being generated
that are out in the wild.
So for the next
generation of models,
you might encounter
the issue of not
finding the true distribution p
data, as we had assumed we had.
And you have some
papers that study
the phenomenon of so-called
model collapse, where
feeding what has been generated
is a way for [AUDIO OUT].
So it looks like an echo chamber
of mistakes that keep growing.
And you see that at the end,
if you represent embeddings
of generations somewhere, you
could clearly cluster the two.
But how could we deal with that?
So that's the kind
of trust point
which is key in our society.
You want to be able
to trust images.
And now these days,
with how similar
the true data distribution
and generated images are,
it seems like the
border is becoming thin.
So two ways to counter that.
There is a norm called C2PA
that has been gaining traction
across software companies.
So you might see this
AI info popping in.
It's because images
that you create with AI
have some of history attached
to it that surfaces it.
So that could be one way to
tackle the data collection
quality issue that
I mentioned before.
But the thing is, if you
take a screenshot of this,
the concept of
metadata disappears.
So are we doomed?
Actually, no.
There are other ways that we
could employ to get around this.
One example is watermarking
with the example of SynthID
from Google DeepMind that
hides behind pixels patterns
that reveal its origin.
So beyond that, you
also have the topic
of safety, which
is very important.
And creating images that
are harmful to others
can have societal implications.
So there is two
parts to fixing this.
One is on the model
side where each company
has their own policies to
guard such generations.
But also law is picking up.
And what can you do from there?
So let's say, this class ends.
How can you be updated?
So one suggestion is to take
a look at the relevant archive
section on computer vision.
But you might see that the
number of submissions every day
is of 100.
So this might not be tractable.
But on the other
hand, some venues
do a good job at distilling
some of these works.
Not all, but they
can give you an idea
of where the field is heading.
And something else that I want
to tell you is all these papers,
we saw a bunch of formulas
all over the place.
And sometimes you just
want to know how they work.
And a great pattern that we see
in academia and in the industry
is that there is code
release of what was
used to design a given method.
So I highly encourage
cloning the GitHub repo
and playing with an AI
assistant coding software
on just getting you
through the flow.
And you will learn a
ton just by doing that.
And beyond that, you
have other resources.
So on Twitter, you have a
growing community of people
who talk about these topics.
So if your For
You page turns out
to be in the clusters
of these topics,
you can get a lot of
interesting recommendations.
And another highlight is other
Stanford courses that talk about
vision, like 231n
that I recommend.
And there is this
study guide that we
shared at the
beginning of the class
that we aim at keeping up
to date across the years.
But beyond all
that, Afshine and I
wanted to say that we are very
happy to come here every Friday
and teach this class
and spend time with you.
It has been a pleasure for us.
And thank you, hidden heroes,
who came here on the evenings
and asked so many
great questions.
You were one of the reasons
why the class was so dynamic
and generated insights
that could then
be useful to everyone.
Thank you also to
those watching online.
Thank you for the great
questions on Ed.
And I hope the class
was of value to you.
And if you are
around in the fall,
Afshine and I will be
teaching a similar class,
but in the text world where
it will be our second edition.
And if you are in
for a new ride,
then we'd love to see you again.
And our favorite teddy bear
is coming one last time
to wish you a great
summer and all the best.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]